[موسيقى]
انا سهى حداد معروفه بصوت نعيمه لاني خلقت
في بيت ميخائيل نعيمه وتربيت على يدي هو
البيت كلمه عن الكلمه من عذابي وولوجيا
وعلى ايدين بنت خالي
[موسيقى]
اول 20 سنه من عمري كانت اخر 20 سنه من
عمر ميخائيل نعيمه من عمره 80 لعمر 99 و4
اشهر
فانا شهدت على كهولته
على زبده الزبده من فكره ومن اخلاقه
[موسيقى]
بهالسنوات ال 20 كان هو الطفل معي انا
الطفله العب انا واياه بيت بيوت ويشرب
قهوه معي بشكل خيالي يقعد معي على الارض
يلاعبني
[موسيقى]
ميخائيل نعيمه كان طفل بيطفولته وكان
صديقني مرافقني بكل عتبه من عتبات حياتي
[موسيقى]
كان جبران خليل جبران نادي ميشا ميخائيل
نعيمه في حياتي هو وجدو ميشا
[موسيقى]
كل شيء بتشوفوها هنا بالبيت من فرش
كنبايات
ثريات
مخطوطات منشوره وغير منشوره اغراضه
الشخصيه من
فرشات الحلاقه
شفره الحلاقه رسميته
[موسيقى]
بدون معيش بالبيت وبهزكريات بتعب بحس انه
هالبيت واللي بيحملوا من هالذكريات ومعاني
واعماء هو الاكسجين لحياتي
[موسيقى]